[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings where for
the first time we're getting a u.s
service member's eyewitness account of
the deadly terrorist attack at kabul's
airport that killed 13 american troops
during the chaotic evacuation there it
was the deadliest day in more than a
decade for the american military in
afghanistan now only on cbs mornings
you're about to hear from one of the
marines who was wounded by those suicide
blasts he spoke with our david martin
who's at the pentagon for us this
morning david good morning what are we
learning
well good morning the marines had
warning
that an attack was coming even had a
physical description of the suspected
bomber but in that crush of humanity
outside the airport they were unable to
spot him
major ben sutfin was there when the bomb
went off right there how far away were
you i was about 15 feet yet he is
somehow alive and able to give the first
eyewitness account of the blast we
brought a
a truck with a loudspeaker down to try
to disperse the crowd i was standing
right by that truck when the bomb went
off the truck shielded you
i'd say so
after the suicide bomber detonated his
vest
gunman opened fire from a nearby roof
sutfin described the actions of a marine
corporal he's blown off his feet
and still has his what's about him shot
through the shoulder immediately
recovers his weapon and puts the
opposing gunman down if they had just uh
opened fire without you firing back what
would have happened without a doubt many
more marine and civilian lives would
have been lost 15 marines were wounded
among them corporal kelsey lainhart her
parents allowed us to show these
pictures of her recovering at walter
reed another corporal
with substantial blast injuries to his
lungs
and internal organs still has enough
grit and courage at risk of his own life
to drag another injured marine
out of harm's way this is where it
happened about 300 yards from abby gate
one of the main entrances to the airport
the marines had set up a corridor
between abby gate and the barren hotel
where british troops were located
on the day of the attack abby gate was
the only way into the airport the other
two gates had been closed for a while
so what was happening is
everyone it looked like the city
converging on abbey gate despite
intelligence warnings of an imminent
attack by a terrorist group known as
isis k abby gates stayed open so british
troops at the hotel could return to the
airport the
the day of the attack we we had gotten
probably the most direct indications of
a threat at the abbey gate
and an individual to look out for so we
made sure that that information was
passed to our marine snipers and and to
the marines on location how difficult
would it be to pick out
one person who you have a description of
i would say next to impossible
in in crowds of thousands
tightly packed shoulder shoulder chest
chest i mean this was a very dense crowd
sutfin who was the operations officer of
his battalion said the marines took
every possible precaution armed aerial
surveillance overhead at the time we had
electronic countermeasures for
improvised explosive device all along
that corridor that would try to
eliminate
any
electronically
triggered device
but the suicide bomber was not detected
and the carnage was horrific
an estimated 170 afghan civilians killed
the airport went into mourning as 13
dead americans were sent home with
honors i'm sure you've asked yourself
this in retrospect
what could you have done differently the
mission was evacuating people we had to
keep that road open there was not a lot
we could change about that situation it
was the mission and we executed it
it was to have been their last mission
abby gate was scheduled to close and
those marines were supposed to return to
the airport
to board planes for the flight out
gail
boy david that's tough to hear was a
terrible terrible day and then to hear
from the major that it could have been
so much worse our thanks to him thanks
to the american military
think of the courage the courage
involved in knowing that there is a
likely attack that day and you still go
out and do your job in the in the line
of danger yeah and when we see words
like support our troops then you have an
opportunity to do to please do because
not only are the heroes in the moment
but when they come back home they still
live with the memories of that troops
are more than just words and we see that